[Musique]
le visage serein Jean-Paul i repose
allongé sur un catafalque dans ses
appartements privés l'homage ému de la
classe politique et des membres de la
cuurrie Romaine demain la dépouille du
pape sera exposée au public dans la
basilique Saint-Pierre on attend plus de
2 millions de pèlerins c'est hier soir à
21h37 que c'est'est éteint le souverain
pontif peu après l'annonce de sa mort
130000 personnes étaient rassemblées sur
la place Saint-Pierre en larme souvent
et en prière mêmes images de
recueillement en Pologne où l'on a
veillé et chanté toute la nuit ce matin
une messe de rkouyem a été célébrée sur
le parvis de la basilique devant une
véritable marée humaine le monde est en
deuil scène de prière en Amérique latine
en Afrique en Chine et dans le monde
arabe trois jours de deuil ont été
décrétés en Égypte à Notre-Dame de Paris
s'achève une messe en présence de
Jacques Chirac et de son épouse plus de
10000 personnes sont sur le parvis dans
ce journal nous serend direct avec tous
nos correspondants les obsèques de
Jean-Paul i pourraient avoir lieu jeudi
ou vendredi prochain George Bush sera
présent ainsi que de nombreux chefs
d'État et de gouvernement voame monsieur
bonsoir avant d'être demain exposé dans
la basilique Saint-Pierre pour que
chacun puisse lui dire adieu Jean-Paul i
repose désormais entouré des siens dans
ses appartements privés la souffrance a
quitté son visage et les principaux
dirigeants italiens et membres de la cue
se sont recueillis à la mi-journée pour
ce premier hommage au pape desfs
christop
le visage de Jean-Paul II serein enfin
apaisé loin des images de souffrance de
l'homme en fin de vie les gardes suisses
continuent de le veiller même dans la
mort la dépouille du Saint-Père est
offerte au regard du
monde ce matin dans la chapelle privée
du pape la mort est officiellement
constatée selon le rituel du Vatican
c'est ensuite l'hommage des plus
proches C sœurs polonaises qui l'ont
accompagné tout au long de son
pontificat ù son secrétaire particulier
Monseigneur
divic en fin de matinée la dépouille est
transférée dans la salle Clémentine du
Palais apostolique c'est l'hommage
officiel des autorités du Vatican du
gouvernement italien et des
diplomates au premier rang le président
du Conseil syvio
[Musique]
Berluscon
le cardinal Camerling Somalo bénit le
corps du
pape des champs grégorien accompagne ces
instants d'intense
recueillement demain dans la basilique
Saint-Pierre la foule des fidèles pourra
à son tour voir Jean-Paul II une
dernière
fois le certificat de décer rendu public
aujourd'hui par le Vatican indique que
le pape est décédé d'un choc septique et
d'une insuffisance cardiaque c'est donc
à 21h37 hier que Jean-Paul i s'est
éteint dans ses appartements privés peu
avant 22h le décès du pape a été annoncé
au Romains comme le veut la tradition
par le vicaire du pape l'annonce de sa
mort a suscité une émotion immense parmi
les fidèles beaucoup n'ont pas pu cacher
leur larmes Paul de
Genève ils attendaient cette annonce
mais la redoutaiit ils étaient plusieurs
milliers place Saint-Pierre de Rome à
veiller pour Jean-Paul II quand vers 22h
Monseigneur Sand des proche du pape
interrom les
prières mes très chers frères et
sœurs à
21h37 notre très aimé Saint-Père
jean-pul I a été rappelé dans la maison
du
Père prions pour
lui la nouvelle est accueillie par de
très longues minutes de
silence la foule immense plonge dans le
deuil
salve
[Musique]
reg les regards se tourne vers les
appartements privés de Jean-P i derrière
C TR fentres encore éclair que c
[Musique]
leand et la cloche de bronze de la
basilique Saint-Pierre de Rome sonne le
glas et annonce au monde la mort de
Carole votiwa le pape jean- i am
grande la V
am et toute la nuit des dizaines de
milliers de croyants sont venus
s'incliner pour prier des visages
emprint d'émotion et de gravité des
fidèles plongés dans la méditation
Jacques cardos Guillaume
fara ils n'ont pas tous la même
expression mais tous sont dans
l'affliction à cet instantl Rome pleure
son pape dans le
silence il a été rappelé dans la maison
de Dieu nous dit le
Vatican abandonn à notre tour de penser
à lui et de
prier d'abord il y a eu le silence un
long silence de recueillement comme une
communion et puis chacun a voulu vivre à
sa façon cette
disparition en brûlant un cierge
seul ou dans le
réconfort je me sens comment
dire de moi'
qué c'est terrible nous avons perdu
notre propre père nous venions d'arriver
à Rome c'est comme s'il nous avait
attendu pour
partir et puis la jeunesse a pris
place pourquoi mourir demande la chanson
refusant la
fatalité pour celui qu'il ne peuvent se
résigner à voir partir ASI malgré sa
longue maladie
[Applaudissements]
j'ai beaucoup de tristesse pour
quelqu'un que j'estimais un grand pape
qui a fait beaucoup pour
nous moi je ressens de la joie parce
qu'à présent il est à côté de
Dieu des milliers de pèlerins venus de
par le monde ont voulu vivre cet instant
alternant chant et applaudissement pour
celu qui auraqué qu de siècle d'histoire
un quart de siècle d'histoire de la
chrétienté et ce matin devant une foule
gigantesque massé place Saint-Pierre et
dans les allées voisinantes s'est
déroulé la messe de rquouyem là où le
pape avait l'habitude lorsqu'il était à
Rome de bénir les pèlerins plus de
devant plus de 100000 personnes ému aux
larmes l'archevêque Leonardo Sandri a lu
le dernier message du pape l'amour
convertit les cœurs et donne la paix
Isabelle St Emmanuel
be mess est finie depuis longtemps mais
ils sont toujours là nombreus et
recueillis sous les fenêtres où ils
avaient l'habitude de voir apparaître
Jean-Paul i parmi les offrandes au pape
disparu quelques messages d'enfant tu es
vivant dans notre cœur ont écrit
Rose-Marie et
Nicolo quand un homme aussi bon que le
pape Jean-Paul II est mort on est là
jusqu'à la fin quoi jusqu'à ses
obsèques ils sont des dizaines de
milliers une foule immense et
silencieuse la disparition de jean-pa i
la grand
il y
manque
manque d'un père de quelqu'un qui proche
tous Jean-Paul i était un grand admu le
cardinal Sodano hier encore numéro 2 du
Vatican dans son homilie il a témoigné
que jean-pa I a vécu son agonie avec
sérénité estti dans la
paix 30 ans qu'il part parce que il
souffrait trop et cette souffrance était
pénible pour nous tous parmi la foule
face à la basilique Saint-Pierre dont
les portes de bronze sont fermées en
signe de deuil beaucoup de jeunes
Jean-Paul I a exprimé une pensée pour
eux la veille de sa
mort nous avons suivi le pape depuis les
JMJ en 2000 jusqu'à maintenant c'est
notre
Pape dans son testament Jean-Paul II a
lancé un appel à l'amour et à la paix
figa non N comme personnalité il n'y a
plus personne aujourd'hui ni mère Teresa
ni Gandy ni Luther King il n'y a plus
personne après
lui sur les écrans vidéo les fidèles ont
pu apercevoir la dépouille mortelle de
Jean-Paul
II ce n'est pas de le voir comme ça qui
m'aime c'est de savoir qu'il est bien
maintenant demain tous les fidèles
pourront rendre hommage au pape Desf
dans la basilique
Saint-Pierre revenons un instant à
l'émotion qui accompagne Ann de la mort
de Jean-P i hier soir ici c'est dans une
petite église tout près de la place
Saint-Pierre que ce prêtre et ses
fidèles ont appris la nouvelle
reportage il est près de 22 dans la
sartie de
l'église le Père Joseph apprend la
nouvelle qu'il
redout dans l'église les fidèles réunis
en prière ne savent pas encore il va
devoir leur annoncer mais avant il
s'isole quelques secondes
puis il interrompt la veillée et se
saisit du
micro à 21h37 le pape est
mort confions au Seigneur le soin de
l'accueillir au
Paradis on peut le dire maintenant tout
est
accompli retournons à notre
prière pour les fidèles commence alors
it de chagrin et de
deuil petit à petit l'église va se
remplir les premiers arriver ne savent
pas
encore vous êtes au courant de la
nouvelle non le pape oui va
mal il est
mort on arrive à peine de chez nous je
ne le savais
pas on attache les drapeaux du Vatican
en signe de
deuil à l'intérieur une messe improvisée
est
organisée le Père Joseph lui reste dans
l'ombre ce soir son église appartient au
fidèles il en sera ainsi une partie de
la
nuit ce matin l'église Santo Spirito
s'est réveillée
orpheline première matinée sans lui il y
a encore ce vide dans mon cœur nous les
jeunes qui sommes nés avec lui grand
avec lui c'est comme si nous avions
perdu un père un grand
père l'église se remplit encore il n'y a
plus une place il faut fermer les portes
pour suivre la messe on installe un
écran sur le parv tous pourront voir le
Père Joseph parler de ce pape qu'ilim
tant tout à coup il sort en pleine messe
ceux qui sont restés dehors pouront eu
aussievoir la
communioniséglise vers la place
Saint-Pierre rejoindre les dizaines de
milliers de fidèles qui s'y trouvent
déjà à Paris il y a 1hure et dem toutes
les églises de la capitale ont sonné le
glas au moment où a commencé la messe
solonnelle à la mémoire de Jean-Paul i à
NotreDame de Paris les cloches qui
résonnent comme le bourdon de la
[Musique]
cathédrale
célébré par Monseigneur André 2 cette
messe solonnelle est en train de
s'achever en présence de Jacques Chirac
et de son épouse et des membres du
gouvernement de très nombreuses
personnalités ont pris place à
l'intérieur de la cathédrale et
notamment des représentants d'autres
religions Caroline Gautier jeanhu blanc
Notre Dame accueille ce soir 6000
fidèles une messe solennelle à la
mémoire de ce géant de l'église et de la
foi le pape Jean-Paul
II monsieur le Président si vous saz à
quel point vous nous touchez et vous
touchez notre
communauté sur le parv monseigne Andr
accue le
président aussi le premier ministre
Jean-Pierre affarin des membres du
gouvernement Anne Hidalgo représente le
maire de Paris Bertrand de laané d'il
boubacur pour le Culte Musulman des
représentants du CRIF aussi toutes les
confessions sont
rassemblées l'archevêque de Paris
accueille cette grande famille champ
liturgique lecture des textes de
l'Évangile puis Monseigneur André 23
prononce l'hommage à Jean-Paul II retour
sur la foi du pape et ses nombreux
[Musique]
engagements confront au grand dictatur
du nazisme et du marxisme
léniniste il a vérifié dans sa propre
existence la puissance de
l'Évangile sa capacité de transformation
sociale comme la victoire finale de la
vérité sur l'empire du mensonge tous ces
combats jeanp II les a mené portés par
son inébranlable chrétienne elle a
renforcé son amour de
l'homme de tous les hommes et sa
conviction que la défense des droits de
l'homme de tous les droits de l'homme
sans en excepter aucun est aussi un
témoignage rendu à la vocation divine de
l'humanité la cérémonie s'achève le
premier hommage officiel de la France au
souverain
pontif
[Musique]
alléu le parvis de NotreDame est noir de
monde depuis le milieu de l'après-midi
sous un soleil éclatant un écran géant
sur lequel on peut voir une immense
photo du pape Jean-Paul II a été
installé et cette foule de fidèles et de
curieux assisté à la messe à l'extérieur
de la cathédrale reportage Frédéric
creeta et jean- y
blanc seuls les plus motivés venus en
début d'après-midi ont pu prendre place
dans la cathédrale allez c'est ferm vous
vous rentrez dans 2h avant le début de
l'Office le service d'ordre est un peu
débordé mais intraitable plus aucune
place disponible à l'intérieur de notre
dame nous on va partir à la maison on
était venu mais bon on
repart mais qu'importe l'essentiel est
d'être là pour prier à la mémoire de
Jean-Paul
II il la souffrance comme le Christ a
montré la sienne moi en tant que jeune
je l'ai suivi avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme et bah même encore
aujourd'hui malheureusement parti C pour
prier une dernière fois lui donner un
ultime
hommage 18h30 début de l'Office un
recueill mon
impressionnant des visages graves
l'heure est à la
méditation chant et prières envahissent
le parvis de Notre Dame où se sont
rassemblés des milieux de
fidèles je pense que je suis au bon
endroit au bon moment j' pas prévu tout
ça et je suis très contente d'être là ça
fait plaisir de de sentir qu'on est pas
seul parce qu'on a souvent tendance à
nous dire que que on a toujours
l'impression d'être tout seul et là
vraiment ça fait plaisir de pas se
sentir seul quo
voilà de ma jeunesse jeis pas vieille
mais quand même j'avais 9 ans quand il a
pris ses fonctions
quo don être
là réuni dans une même ferveur ces
milliers de chrétiens étai là pour
remercier Jean-P I lui dire au revoir
donne Seigneur donne le
salut et sur le parv de Notre Dame nous
vous retrouvons le de la mornaete depuis
la nuit dernière des milliers de fidèles
se sont retrouvés pour prier dans la
cathédrale après une nuit de veillée les
Parisiens ont donc choisi de venir
extrêmement extrêmement nombreux ce soir
pour rendre un dernier hommage au pape
oui Béatrice la cérémonie vient de se
terminer vous entendez encore les
cloches derrière moi c'est vrai qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'assez unique ce
soir sur le parvis de de Notre-Dame il
faut d'abord bien imaginer cette foule
immense les derniers chiffres de l'AR de
l'archevêcher de Paris donne 25000
personnes présentes sur le parvis s000 à
l'intérieur de la cathédrale cela
débordait de partout il y avait même des
personnes sur les sur les quêtes scèes
il faut imaginer aussi cette place avec
cette cathédrale et tous les bâtiments
publics alentour qui avaient leur
drapeau en berne et puis surtout
imaginez cette messe géante en plein
Paris en plein air avec des moments
assez touchants avec donc quasiment
30000 personnes qui chantaient le Notre
Père ensemble par exemple ou qui tout
simplement
se donnait la main et s'embrassait
lorsque le prêtre a demandé de se donner
la paix alors l'archevêque de Paris
justement dans son omélé a rappeler le
rôle de transformateur social de
Jean-Paul II il a dit aussi que c'était
l'une des personnes qui avait le plus
tendu les bras vers les autres religions
enfin et surtout il a surtout rappelé
son amour de l'homme son amour de tous
les hommes et cela c'est justement le
message de Jésus-Christ merci loï de la
mornete vous venez de le dire les
drapeaux sont en berne et Jacques Chirac
dès ce matin a tenu à à exprimer homage
de la France au pape Jean-Paul i je vous
propose de
l'écouter je veux exprimer l'hommage de
la France à celui qui aura porté avec
ferveur conviction courage de façon
incomparable une parole
d'espérance pour tous les peuples du
monde l'humanité perd un pasteur
inspiré défenseur inlassable de la
dignité de
l'homme Jean-Paul II n'aura eu de cesse
de montrer à tous les peuples à tous les
hommes le chemin de la Concorde et de la
solidarité il laera une profonde
empreinte dans la mémoire de tous
chrétien et non chrétien en Pologne cet
après-midi plus de 100000 personnes ont
assisté à une messe en pleinaire là où
Jean-Paul II avait célébré la messe
mémorable lors de son premier voyage
officiel en 79 dans son pays à l'époque
Jean-Paul i avait exhorté les Polonais à
ne pas avoir peur des paroles
historiques qui sonnaient comme un appel
à la résistance face au régime
communiste partons maintenant pour le
village natal de Jean-Paul I avadovit
qui est déjà un lieu de pèlerinage
chaque ruelle chaque bâtiment porte le
souvenir de Carole vochtilla lorsqu'il
était jeune reportage sur place maris
Burgot Nathalie
galet les couleurs jaunes et blanches du
Vatican au-dessus de vadovit
[Musique]
la ville natale de Jean-Paul II pleure
son enfant prodige Carole votila baptisé
dans cette église en
1920 un dimanche en famille sous un
splendide soleil un dimanche marqué par
l'omniprésence d'un disparu considéré
ici comme un
saint le prêtre de la paroisse enchaîne
les interviews avec les télévisions
venues du monde entier il constate que
la disparition de Jean-Paul i restera un
traumatisme une blessure pour les
habitants de
vadovit impossible pour tous d'accéder à
l'église alors la maison où vivait
jean-pa i jusqu'à 18 ans devient un lieu
de recueillement c'est aujourd'hui un
musée où l'on sétonne de voir que ce
visage de bébé est bien celui de jean-pa
i devant une paire de ski qui avait
appartenu à Carole votila cette femme
explique qu'il est bon de se souvenir de
l'époque où le pape était un grand
sportif dehors à midi précise les
habitants de vadovitz se donnent la main
à l'intérieur de l'église ont bâtise
trois enfants la vie
continue la ville de vadovit deviendra
certainement un lieu de pèlerinage parce
que Jean-Paul II prier pape slave de
l'histoire est né ici des milliers de
catholiques viendront désormais avadovit
sur les traces de l'enfant prodige de la
Pologne à kracovi cet après-midi sous le
premier soleil de printemps ils sont des
milliers à se retrouver autour du
souvenir du père disparu une messe et un
gigantesque pique-nique comme pour
commencer le travail de deuil Gill
Rabine Franck
Brisset parce qu'il reste désemparé par
la perte de l'homme qui les a guidé tout
au long de leur
vie ils ont éprouvé le besoin de se
rassembler
[Musique]
je me sens mieux ici que seul chez moi à
regarder la
télévision plus de 100000 personnes sont
ven aujourd'hui assister à cette me en
plein au PES
decov même certains de ceux qui ne cro
plus en
Dieu autorité morale pour tous même pour
qui c
pas aujourd'hui dans la même prière
c'est parce qu'il y a un quart de siècle
jean-pa i leur a donné le même espoir à
partager parce qu'aujourd'hui était un
des tout premiers vrais jours de
printemps la messe s transformé en
piquenique ce qui n'aurait pas choqué le
pape desfs au
contraire je garderai le souvenir d'un
homme g d'un homme bon le meilleur qui
soit dit cette jeune
femme sa bonté il l'a donné au monde
entier ajoute cette jeune
sœuro tous mais surtout au jeunes il
restera toujours à nos côtés affirme ce
jeune
homme làhaut il doit déjà prier pour
nous conclu cette toute jeune
grand-mère avant la messe en pleinir et
le piqueenque dans kracovie à mid
pile tous se sont arrêtés là où ils étai
pour former une chaîne humaine main dans
la main le temps d'une prière en hommage
à Jean-P
i en Pologne tous les drapeau sont
comme à kracovi où Caro voch passé sa
vie d'adulte là où il a étéê archevêque
puis cardinal les fidèles d l'annonce de
la mort du pape avec des couvertures et
des chaises pliantes se sont rendu au
sanctuaire de la miséricorde divine dans
un quartier de la ville une veillée fun
g Rabine naalie Gal fr
Briss hier soir à l'annonce de la mort
du Pape le temps s'est arrêté à kracovi
l'espace d'une nuit un peuple tout
entier littéralement tombé en prière et
en pleur
le guide est parti à cette fenêtre il y
a 3 ans lors de son dernier voyage en
Pologne Jean-Paul i leur avait dit qu'il
ne reverrait sans doute plus jamais sa
terre
natale et il les avait prévenu je vous
ai rendu la liberté dit débrouillez-vous
pour vous fabriquer un
avenir ils vont devoir le faire sans
[Musique]
lui devenu pape la Pologne vivait une
nuit communiste qui paraissait alors
sans fin derrière le rideau de fer au
plus fort de la guerre froide au moment
où il s'en va sa Pologne est membre de
l'Union européenne elle est libre elle a
retrouvé sa
fierté dans l'église mariai cou il fut
évêque de kracovi la messe a duré toute
la nuit pour certains de ses fidèles les
voûtes raisonnent encore des prêches qu'
y donnit un jour dans cette église le
futur jean-pa II avait lancé écoutez le
cri de l'homme et vous entendrez le cri
de
Dieu en hommage à Jean-Paul 2 tout
kracovie est réuni en ce moment même aux
portes de la ville pour une messe en
plein air qui doit réunir plus de 100000
personnes à la fin de la messe dans tout
le pays les fidèles doivent former une
immense chaîne humaine main dans la main
à travers les villes les routes et les
champs en duplexe de kracovie nous vous
retrouvons Gill Rabine la Pologne est en
deuil un deuil national de plusieurs
jours les Polonais pleurent celui qui en
fait les a fait entrer dans dans le 3è
millénaire
oui il leur a ouvert les portes du 21e
siècle et il leur a tout simplement
donné un avenir dans le fameux n'ayez
pas peur qu'il avait lancé au tout début
de son pontificat Jean-Paul le disait
ouvrez les portes à la puissance
salvatrice du Christ 25 ans plus tard un
quart de siècle plus tard il a redonné
un espoir aux Polonais il avait ajouté
ouvrez les frontières des États et ce
peuple de Pologne qui était à l'époque
l'otage de l'Empire communiste
soviétique est libre aujourd'hui de
décider de son destin ses frontières se
sont ouvertes alors il reste au Polonais
il reste maintenant au Polonais comme à
tous les autres d'ailleurs à apprivoiser
dans leur mémoire les images des années
de souffrance de Jean-Paul II pour Red
découvrir la force et l'universalité de
son message merci Gill Rabine le monde
entier est en prière et dès l'annonce du
décès de Jean-Paul i les réactions
officielles de la communauté
internationale se sont bien sûr
multipliées George Bush et le prof qui a
rendu hommage à ce héros pour l'éternité
le président américain assistera aux
obsèques du pape ce sera la première
fois qu'un président américains
participent à des funérailles
pontificales en Amérique latine qui
compte 500 millions de catholiques sur
ce continent d'une grande ferveur et
d'une grande piété image aussi de
consternation et de larme partout les
cloches des églises se sont mises à
sonner le Brésil pleur et rent hommage
au pape Bertrand coq et Yan moine se
sont rendus dans les quartiers
populaires de Sao Poulo pour assister à
la messe d'un jeune prêtre très
charismatique le prêtre des pauvres qui
emploie à sa façon les méthodes
évangélistes dans une première vie le
père Marcelo était prof de gym il en a
gardé les manières d'un entraîneur pour
motiver ses
oilles en l'occurrence 800 bénévoles
entièrement dévoués à sa personne et à
son
message au Brésil ce curé de 38 ans est
une star grand admirateur de Paul 2 dont
il applique la consigne n'attendez pas
que les fidèles viennent à vous allez
les
chercher j'ai de la nostalgie pour son
amour dit-il mais pas de tristesse la
tristesse tue je le dis à mes fidèles
elle est inutile d'ailleurs le pape n'en
aurait pas voulu son successeur d'après
le père Marcelo ne devrait pas changer
le message de l'église notamment sur le
préservatif mais au contraire devrait
poursuivre l'œuvre de Jean-Paul II
9h du matin le père Marcelo monte en
scène
son temple une usine désaffectée son
public une assemblée très métissée de
gens simples que la vie n'a pas
épargné nous sommes chez les
charismatiques où le corps participe à
la prière la messe dure 2 he Rym par des
chansons à l'extérieur se tient
uneermess de la piété mélange de
fétichisme et de culte de la
personnalitéète pourant la soif de
croire de peuple brésilien je sucita la
ferveur c'était un pape informel qui
aimait la modernité qui était joyeux
ouvert et libre et c'est cette
allégresse que nous retrouvons ici avec
le père
Marcelo ici je chante je danse je pleure
je ris et je partage ma
joie omniprésent dans les médias le père
Marcelo utilise les méthode des
télépasteurs américains avec lui la
messe est un spectacle au service de
l'évangélisation
dans un pays où l'influence de la
télévision est immense et qui pratique
le culte des vedettes le père Marcelo se
sert de son image pour toucher le cœur
des fidèles Jean-Paul II qui l'avait
rencontré en 97 ne faisait pas autre
chose et puis il y a l'hommage du monde
arabe l'Égypte vient de décréter un
deuil officiel de 3 jours et on
retiendra que les deux principales
chaînes de télé aljesera et Alarabia ont
retransmis en direct l'agonie et la mort
de Jean-Paul II du jamais vu ajoutons
que la télévision du Hezbollah elle-même
interrompu ses programmes pour annoncer
la mort du pape dans les haut lieux
sains du christianisme maintenant à
Jérusalem et à Bethléem la communauté
catholique est en prière les chrétiens
de Terre Sainte sont en deuil à Nazareth
était célébré une messe devant quelques
2000 fidèles par ailleurs les deux
grands rabins d'Israël ont rendu hommage
au pape un ami du peuple juif hommage
appuyé également d'Ariel Charon le
Premier ministre enfin sachez que
d'istanou celui qui avait tenté
d'assassiner Jean-Paul II en 1981 et qui
est en prison aliaxa s'est dit
extrêmement triste il aimait le pape
dit-il le Saint-Père qui d'ailleurs plus
de 2 ans après la tentative d'attentat
avait rendu visite à son agresseur une
façon de lui indiquer qu'il lui avait
pardonné repartons à présent pour Rome
la ville éternelle se prépare à
accueillir dès demain une immense foule
de pèlerins qui vont d'abord se
recueillir devant la dépouille de
Jean-Paul II puis viendra le temps des
obsèques Rome qui s'organise pour que
cet événement se déroule au mieux le
cœur de Rome c'est en ce moment le
Vatican Gérard
rom Rome est déserte ce matin la ville
éternelle donnait l'impression d'avoir
émigré place Saint-Pierre les drapeaux
sont en Bern les jardins de la Villa
borgaise ont rarement été si paisibles
pourtant les bus sont bondés mais il
vont tous au
Vatican on ressent ce sentiment de deuil
en ce moment l'absence du pape se Ress
vraiment sur la place du du peuple le
marchand de journaux est bien discret
moi je ne voulais pas venir aujourd'hui
par respect je suis là je vend mes
journaux mais pas à la
crier un autre monde agite la gare de
Termini où 150 trains supplémentaires
ont été affraités le lieu est maintenant
ouvert 24h sur 24 et la protection
civile a pris les choses en
main nous n'avons pas encore été
informés de l'arrivée de trains spéciaux
en provenance d'autres pays mais nous ne
sommes qu'à 24 heures de la mort du pape
dans les prochains jours la situation
peut
changer c'est vrai que les Romains ont
l'habitude de gérer l'arrivée massive de
pelin après les JMJ puis le Jubilé de
l'an 2000 dès demain s'il le faut 8000 l
d'eau pourront être fournis chaque jour
en attendant une aire d'évacuation
d'urgence a été tracée tout le long de
l'avenue qui débouche sur le
vaticanard grisbec vous êtes à Rome on
ignore pour l'instant la date précise
des funérailles mais on sait déjà que le
président américain sera présent comme
bien d'autres chefs d'État et c'est un
un incroyable dispositif qui est en
train de se mettre en place
oui vous avez raison vous savez ces
obsèques on pense qu'ils auront lieu au
moin auront lieu jeudi ou vendredi on le
SAA vraiment que demain mais en tout cas
déjà on prend beaucoup de mesures de
sécurité ici mais vous savez les
Italiens ont l'habitude des sommets ils
ont l'habitude des grandes réunions
internationales bien sûr les mesures
seront renforcées des milliers de
policiers déjà sont en place et on pense
qu'effectivement tout se passera alors
effectivement demain on connaîtra le
calendrier les cardinau vont commencer à
se réunir pour décider non seulement de
la date des obsèques mais de la date
également du conclave qui devra avoir
lieu d'ici 3 semaines et c'est lors de
ce conclave qu'un successeur de
Jean-Paul II sera choisi alors
évidemment on n'est pas en campagne
électorale on est plutôt dans la
préparation des obsèques mais quand même
un certain nombre de cardinaux parlent
alors il ne parlent pas de nom mais il
parle de profil de Pape et on entend
même quelques critiques sur la façon
dont Jean-Paul II aur gérer l'église on
lui reproche sans doute d'avoir été un
peu trop pèlerin à travers le monde et
de ne pas être resté suffisamment ici au
Vatican pour gérer l'église merci Gérard
c'est dans la crypte de la basilique
Saint-Pierre que Jean-Paul II devrait
être enterré on ignore s'il a laissé un
testament privé mais d'ors et déjà des
travaux sont en cours à l'intérieur de
la crypte Bernard lebrin romain
potecky sous le sol de marbre de la
basilique Saint-Pierre repose depuis des
siècles nombre des 264 successeurs de
l'apôtre Pierre dans cette crypte que
l'on appelle le sépulcre ou la grotte
des papes se trouve les tombeaux de
Jean-Paul i Paul 6 mais aussi
p a priori le corps de jean-pa i devrait
y reposer à jamais après ses funérailles
théoriquement ça être là mais il y a
beaucoup de légendes qui circulent au
sujet
de car les Polonais évidemment
souhaitait qu'il soit intéré en Pologne
et
apparemment selon certains polonais il
aurait pu être interré au même cimetière
près de vadovitz ou son intérêt enfin
intérêt sa famille mais on n sait rien
il y a surtout les dernières volontés de
Jean-Paul II toujours inconnu tant que
son testament n'est pas ouvert mais son
entourage se souvient que lors de ce
dernier voyage sur la tombe de ses
parents le pape avait évoquer le souhait
de demeurer près d'e et puis il y a
aussi dans la ville natale du pape
rumeur tenace en forme de revendication
la dépouille de Jean-Paul II reposerait
bien dans la crypte de Saint-Pierre de
Rome mais c'est ici dans la petite
église de vadovitz où caroy voltila fut
baptisé en 1920 que son cœur serait
conservé tel une relique religieuse et
nationale aux dernières nouvelles des
travaux seraient en cours dans la crypte
de Saint-Pierre précisément là où se
trouvait le tombeau de jean2 et qui
repose désormais dans la basilique
depuis sa béatification dans cette
période de transition c'est le cardinal
camerlin qui est la plus haute autorité
du Vatican et les cardinaux tiendront
demain leur première réunion pour
préparer les funérailles de jean-pa i
une réunion essentielle puisque c'est là
que sera établi le calendrier des
obsèes le camerl Somalo qui a procédé ce
matin au R de la constatation de la mort
du pape est désormais le personnage
central du Vatican c'est lui qui assure
l'intérim à la tête de l'État à la mort
du pape tous les haut responsables du
gouvernement ont été automatiquement
démis de leur fonction Jean-Paul 2 a
choisi le cardinal Somalo pour veiller à
l'organisation de ses obsèes c'est donc
lui qui a décidé d'exposer demain à 17h
le corps du pape au fidèle c'est à
lui'est revenu l'honneur de détruire
l'Anneau apostolique qui authentifie la
signature du
pape dès demain les 180 cardinaux
accourus du monde entier se retrouveront
en congrégation sous la présidence du
Camerling ils organiseront les
funérailles pontificales elles se
tiendront entre jeudi et samedi les
cardinaux décideront de la date du
conclave car ils sont les faiseurs de
Pape l'élection du successeur de
Jean-Paul II pourra commencer dans 15
jours dans la Constitution qu'il a
rédigé en
1996 Jean-Paul II avait été dicté tous
les détails de ses obsèques ainsi le
souverain pontif avait-il précisé qu'il
souhaitait contrairement à la tradition
que ses collaborateurs puissent demeurer
dans ses appartements jusqu'à ses
funérailles reste une grande
interrogation le papa a-t-il laissé un
testament il s'est en tout cas réservé
le droit de le
faire secrétaire particulier du pape
Monseigneur Devic vivait 24 he sur 24
avec Jean-Paul II et depuis tant
d'années c'est sans doute celui qui a le
mieux connu et accompagné le pape jusque
dans ces tout derniers moment cet archev
polonais toujours très discret était
jusqu'àors un prélat incontournable
quand sera-t-il
demain si vous cherchez stanislasiv
cherchez jean-pa i il est toujours près
de lui que ce soit dans la PAP mobile au
fenêtres de l'hôpital Gelli ou du
Vatican au retour d'un voyage ou lors
d'une messe car don Stanislas comme on
l'appelle à Rome ne quitte jamais le
pape il était même à ses côtés ce 13 mai
81 lors de la tentative d'assassinat de
Jean-Paul II sur la place Saint-Pierre
il l'a soutenu durant tout le trajet
jusqu'à
l'hôpital les deux hommes sont des amis
de 40 ans ils se seraient rencontrés sur
des pistes de ski à zacopan en Pologne
il a une grande amour pour les papes
c'est quasi une relation de père un fils
il est très fidèle et il il a toujours
supporté les dans les situ dès son
élection Jean-Paul II le fait venir à
Rome comme secrétaire particulier il
était déjà son secrétaire à kracovi et
il avait accompagné Carolle votila à
Rome pour le Concile Vatican 2 c'était
dans les années
60 avec la maladie le rôle de
stanislivic n'a fait que croîre avant
lui tous les secrétaires des PAP on joué
le même rôle dans les période de fin de
règne il deviennent incontournaable si
l'on veut connaître le sentiment du
Saint-Père un rôle qui ne peut provoquer
que des jalousies voire des rancœurs et
lorsque l'on sait que l'entourage le
plus proche de Jean-Paul i cinq
religieus dwitch et son adjoint sont
tous polonais on comprend mieux le
sentiment de Roget qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui après la mort de Jean-Paul
II les cardinaux du monde entier font
route vers Rome ils sont 117 qui se
retrouveront d'ici une quinzaine de
jours en conclave dans la chapelle six
et c'est eux qui éliront le successeur
de Jean-Paul i parmi les favoris voici
une liste de ces papa Billy qui viennent
de plusieurs continents leur portrait
avec Philippe
aroir de ce collège des cardinaux
sortira le prochain pape même s'il
suffit selon le droit canon d'être
baptisé pour devenir pape le souverain
pontif a toute chance d'être élu parmi
les cardinaux de moins de 80 ans réunis
en conclave comme le veut la tradition
après le très long et riche pontificat
de Jean-Paul II les cardinaux seront
peut-être tentés de choisir un PAP de
transition histoire de souffler le
cardinal Angelo Sodano 77 ans le plus
proche collaborateur du défin pape
pourrait s'imposer naturellement le
cardinal allemand Joseph Ratzinger 77
ans est aussi bien placé gardien du
dogme depuis 24 ans il avait la
confiance absolue de Jean-Paul II mais
ses positions strictes sur la doctrine
ont heurté parfois ses confrères les
plus libér nul doute qu'il aura un rôle
clé dans le choix du nouveau
pape s'il est vrai que les Italiens
souhaitent reprendre possession du trône
apostolique un autre cardinal de la
curie Giovanni Baptista reé 70 ans a
toutes ses chances patron des évêques
proche de l'ancien pape il connaît les
rages du saint-sège et a été
diplomate parmi les cardinaux de terrain
goniji tetamanzi 70 ans archevêque de
Milan peut rallier les suffrages à la
fois conservateur et progressistes il
est populaire et dirige le plus
important diocèse italien
[Applaudissements]
à 64 ans Angelo Scola patriarche de
Venise a été considéré souvent comme
l'étoile montante de l'épiscopat jeune
cardinal spécialiste des questions
familiales il peut-être décerdi par son
âge et si le pape venait d'Amérique
latine région la plus catholique du
monde le cardinal brésilien Claudio umch
68 ans est une figure emblématique
brillant théologien fin intellectuel ce
franciscin est archevêque de San Paolo
l'Argentin George Mario bergolio de
buenoser 68 ans est un cardinal dont on
parle mais c'est un jésuite un pape
jésuite ce serait une
première un nom souvent cité le cardinal
Rodriguez Maradiaga 63 ans archevêque de
tgousigalpa au Honduras pré la brillant
et intelligent ami du cardinal Sodano
originaire d'un petit pays ce qui est un
avantage
si les cardinaux s'offraent l'audace
d'élire un pape africain ce qui est peu
probable le cardinal nigérian Francis
Arinze 72 ans apparaît comme possible il
est responsable au Vatican du culte et
des
sacrement les cardinaux guidés par le
Saint-Esprit devront choisir le
265e successeur de Saint-Pierre dans le
secret de la chapelle six sans en rendre
compte à personne sur la terre et
philiip haroir sans vraiment le dire
c'est déjà une campagne électorale
souterrainee qui a commencé au Vatican
et chacun sans doute alimente et active
ses réseaux s Réau peut-être que le mot
campagne électorale pourrait choquer
mais enfin c'est presque ça il y a la on
on l'a dit les congrégations qui vont se
réunir les congrégations officielles si
je puis dire de cardinaux mais il se
passe une chose à Rome avant un conclave
moi j'y étaé au moment de de Jean-Paul i
c'est que des cardinaux des groupes de
cardinaux rencontrent des tas de gens se
rencontrent entre eux rencontre des
prêtres rencontent même des hommes
politiques rencontre des ambassadeurs
ils veulent savoir ils veulent humer
savoir exactement ce que pensent
certaines personnes ça leur donne une
idée pour leur propre choix donc c'est
ça qu'on peut appeler une campagne
électorale mais c'est pas vraiment une
campagne électorale vraiment alors
globalement il y a ceux qui sont pour un
retour à un pontificat plus calme dans
ces cas-là sans doute sont favoris les
Italiens alors la grande question est-ce
que le pape viendra de l'hémisphère nord
ou de l'hémisphère Sud où sont m c'est
la plus grande partie des du monde
entier oui parce que c'est c'est un ça
va être un conclave éclaté vous voyez
c'est c'est très ouvert il y a 170 117
cardinaux mais qui représente 60 pays
qui se connaissent plus ou moins bien
les les cardinaux donc ça va être un peu
difficile c'est pour ça qu'il faut le
préparer avant c'est très important la
phase de la préparation parce que ce
sont des groupes de cardinaux qui se
forment et qui finalement arrivent à
élir l'un d'entre eux mais on dit que
jean-pul 2 avait préparé sa sa
succession de quelle façon je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas du tout s'il a
vraiment préparé est-ce qu'il a remis
une note à quelqu'un est-ce qu'il en a
parlé enant en ant un certain nombre de
nouveaux cardinaux par exemple oui mais
enfin vous savez tous les cardinaux
qu'il a né n'était pas toujours d'accord
avec tout ce qu'il a décidé alors donc
c'est pas sûr du tout que voilà on verra
une dernière une dernière question la
tâche du nouveau pape sera pas facile
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de dossiers
délicac je dirais des dossiers qui sont
en panne VO et très difficile parce que
voyez le pape à Jean-Paul II
charismatique acteur de la
mondialisation médiatique et tout a a
fait une chose ex extrêmement importante
c'est qu'il a redonné à l'église
catholique une image punch une image
vibrante mais souvent derrière cette
image il y avait des faiblesses et des
difficultés par exemple de deux exemples
la vocation lesé voocation la pratique
religieuse exactement qui baisse de plus
en plus ou alors alors surtout chez nous
enfin dans dans dans notre Europe mais
dans les pays du tiers monde une
concurrence religieuse avec des sectes
avec des communautés évangéliques
l'intégrisme et puis le le pape
lorsqu'il parle il parle pour tout le
monde mais tout le monde sait quoi c'est
1 milliard de catholiques éparpillés
dans le monde entier donc tout le monde
l'entend mais tout le monde ne comprend
pas de la même manière donc ça c'est
aussi une tâche très importante qui
attend le nouveau pape et puis le
principal handicap qu'il aura c'est
qu'il succède à un pape exceptionnel
merci Philippe haroir en Afrique
maintenant au Sénégal dans ce pays à
grande majorité musulmane le président
wad a salué l'avocat des pauvres des
malades des femmes et des enfants
plusieurs mes se sont tenus à la
cathédrale reportage ériic Meier sur
place et gu
luconi la cathédrale de Dakar a fait le
plein de fidèle et d'émotion ce
matin dans ce pays à forte majorité
musulmane les catholiques forment une
minorité visible et respectée tout le
monde se souvient que le premier
président élu de la toute jeune
république indépendante sénégalaiseop
saror fut un catholique fervant cette
terre du
Sénégal embrassé comme il avait
l'habitude de le faire à chacun de ses
voyages c'était il y a 13 ans déjà
beaucoup de Sénégalais on gardent le
souvenir il a permis une
réconciliation il a
encore permis une certaine communion
entre les différentes confessions et il
fallait être au Sénégal en 92 pour le
savoir il nous a fait prendre conscience
de la force que représente l'Afrique
dans la chrétiené alors n'est-il pas
tant que le que le prochain pape soit
africain je crois que la couleur
l'appartenance raciale ethnique n'a pas
d'importance ce qu'il a transfendé dans
les mémoires aussi les excuses de
Jean-Paul II au nom de la chrétienté
pour le rôle de l'Église dans la traite
négrière selon ses propres mot ce péché
de l'homme contre l'homme et donc de
l'homme contre
Dieu les catholiques du Sénégal mais
aussi beaucoup de musulmans ont rendu
toute la journée un hommage au défunt
pape le président sénégalais abdouah wad
fut l'un des premiers en saluant
Jean-Paul II un ami de l'Afrique en
Chine maintenant Pékin souhaite que
s'établisse de meilleures relations avec
le Vatican le Gouvernement présente
officiellement ses condoléances les
catholiques de Chine qui ont prié pour
Jean-Paul II durant ce weekend dans ce
pays où la liberté de culte est contrôlé
la Chine est un des rares pays où ne
s'est jamais rendu Jean-Paul II en
France hier soir à lourde le glacené en
fin d'après-midi tout comme hier soir et
ce matin 84 coups pour marquer l'âge du
pape c'est peu aès 22h que les pèlerins
qui revenaient d'une procession ont
appris la mort du pape en entendant les
cloches une messe s'est déroulée à la
grotte où Bernadette avait vu apparître
la Vierge Marie franc
isab prière et recueillement dans la
grotte de lourd ce matin pour les
malades jean-pul I qui est venu ici les
14 et 15 août dernier est désormais un
exemple exemple de dignité dans la
souffrance jusqu'à sa mort hier soir
sûr que il avit un courage oui un
courage pour tout le monde pour tous les
malades depuis le lever du jour une
prière spéciale pour le pape desfs est
dite lors de chaque messe certains
fidèles ont le sentiment d'avoir perdu
un
proche c'est comme si j'avais perdu mes
parents c'est tout ce que je peux dire
pourquoi ça monsieur ben parce que je
l'aimais bien j'en ai pas beaucoup aimé
j'en ai connu pas mal j'ai 80 ans mais c
là je l'aimé j'étais en admiration dev
ventrer en courage maintenant qu'il est
décédé je pense que il faut lui
souhaiter la paix et c'est tout
quoi hier soir la cloche a sonné le glas
pendant de longues
minutes ces drapeaux jaunes et blanc aux
couleur du Vatican ont été mis en
berne ce matin les commerçants de la
ville se sont associés au deuil il
représentaiit encore plus d'espoir je
crois pour les malades quoi ça c'est
c'est vraiment important c'est ce qu'on
a ressenti nous l'année dernière ici les
gens ils en
attendaient le miracle Jean-Paul i
restera sans doute l'un des paples les
plus vénérés par les 6 millions de
pèlerins qui chaque année visitent les
sanctuaires de lourd beaucoup de jeunes
Français se préparent à partir pour Rome
Nabila tabouré Michel Guillaume ont
rencontré l'une d'elles Karine 29 ans
catholique pratiquante quitte Paris dès
ce soir pour assister aux obsèes de
Jean-Paul i un PUL pour
l'éveiller sa décision de partir à Rome
Karine l'a prise il y a à peine 2 he
cela pourrait ressembler à un coup de
tête mais il s'agit surtout d'un coup de
cœur catholique pratiquante cette jeune
femme de 29 ans a été affecté par la
mort du pape ce voyage Karine l'envisage
d'abord comme un moment de communion
avec d'autres catholiques b Ce so sur
place là on a il y a rien d'organisé je
pense que on est tous un peu dans le
même esprit c'est c'est juste c'est le
simple histoire de de partir et sur
place on s'arrangera on a tous pris un
sac de couchage pense queê un moment de
partage en plus c'est que et puis
beaucoup d'émotions en fait à partager
hein au test de l'air au long cours
Karine profite de quelques jours de
repos pour partir à Rome Jean-Paul II
elle a déjà eu l'occasion de
l'apercevoir c'était au Vatican mais son
souvenir le plus émouvant reste les JMJ
en
1997 le pape était venu en France à la
rencontre des jeunes catholiques on est
tous un peu un peu touchés hein surtout
que quand on voit le le milliers de
personnes qui avaient à Rome ou dans
tous les pays du monde je pense que
c'est vraiment une des seules personnes
un peu au monde qui puisse toucher comme
ça un tel un tel nombre de personnes et
c'est vrai queelle se retrouver à Rome
demain ben je pense que c'est ça va être
beaucoup d'émotion Karine par cette nuit
avec quatre autres jeunes elle espère
pouvoir se recueillir devant la
dépouille de Jean-Paul II dès
demain l'apôtre de l'appel le pape sans
frontières sans aucun doute Jean-Paul II
était le plus médiatique des souverains
pontifs il a su s'en servir pour servir
l'église pas un de ses voyages pas un de
ses gestes et de ses souffrances qui
n''est été retransmis à la télévision
Stéphane
il n'y a pas si longtemps l'église d'en
haut s'adressait encore au fidèles d'en
bas du haut d'un perchoir la chaise
pontificale Jean-Paul i lui oublira
d'emblé ce mode de locomotion pour bénir
la foule il se met au contact direct du
peuple le pape est un souverain pontif
que l'on peut toucher non sans risque
pour sa sécurité avant lui le pape était
inaccessible pour les médias là aussi
jean-pa i bouscule les habitudes il va
au devant des journalistes et c'est man
l'humour
se trouver en face des journalistes est
une chose un peu
dangereuse je ne sais pas à quelle
altitude nous nous trouvons maintenant
10000 m alors peut-être à cette altitude
c'est un peu moins
dangereux nous sommes en 95 jean-pa I
est aux Philippines 4 millions de
fidèles sont venus l'acclamer devant eux
le pape fait son show à 75 ans il joue
avec sa canne à la manière de Charlot et
suscite l'allesse populaire
Jean-Paul I est un communiquant moderne
il s'adapte aux célébrations où la
variété côtoie le recueillement et
l'intense émotion comme ici où le pape
discute par satellite avec une fillette
de sarevo l'essentiel reste pour lui la
diffusion de son message jean-pa i grand
communiant mais aussi bon diplomate
jamais pris au dépourvu une question qui
nous tourment beaucoup n c'est les ESS
nucléaires qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez supprimer les
oui fa contrôler en tout cas la France à
sa
raison le pape est aussi surtout un
globe trotteur qui soigne son image
d'homme de paix à chaque descente
d'avion il se baisse et embrasse le sol
du pays visité devant les caméras le
pontificat de Jean-Paul II est ponctué
par les audiences au Vatican le mercredi
autant d'apparitions publi qui marquent
ses visiteurs et c'est lui qui est en
première ligne pour la célébration des M
de l'année chrétienne la cérémonie du
jeudi saint et le lavement des pieds le
chemin de croix du vendredi saint le
pape médiatique s'efface alors devant un
Jean-Paul i mystique mais il est
impossible d'évoquer le succès
médiatique de Jean-Paul i sans parler de
son succès auprès des jeunes la jeunesse
il en a fait la priorité de son
pontificat il n'aura de cesse de
s'adresser à
[Applaudissements]
elle une vie toujours plus
belle fond sur des valeurs moral et
spirituell c'est sans doute l'une des
images les plus fortes que nous
retiendrons de la fin du pontificat
celle d'un pape en communion avec les
jeunes vrais fan des Woodstock
catholiques un Jean-Paul i amuseur et
amusé avant de refermer ce journal
repartons vers Rome vers vous Isabelle
stè demain donc la dépouille de
Jean-Paul II sera présentée à la
basilique Saint-Pierre on attend des
centaines de milliers de pèlerins qui
confluent vers Rome
actuellement oui encore ce soir il y a
beaucoup de pèlerins qui vont et qui
viennent vers la la place Saint-Pierre à
21h il y aura une nouvelle prière pour
Jean-Paul II et c'est donc une nouvelle
veillée de prière qui s'annonce ici sur
la place Saint-Pierre et il en sera
probablement ainsi jusque aux obsès de
Jean-Paul II et puis juste derrière moi
il y a un un kiosque à journaux et
depuis maintenant plus d'une heure et
bien il y a une file d'attente
interminable pour acheter l'observator
et Romano l'Observatoire romain qui est
le journal de du Vatican c'est sa sa
dernière édition à la Une il y a la la
la dépouille mortelle de Jean-Paul II et
ce titre le pape qui est un un géant
dans qui restera un géant dans
l'histoire depuis 2000 ans alors vous
l'avez dit tous ces fidèles pourront dès
demain donc venir rendre hommage à
Jean-Paul i devant sa dépouille mortelle
qui sera exposée dans qui sera exposée
pardon dans la basilique Saint-Pierre on
parle de 1 à 2 millions de pèlerins qui
pourraient venir ici et vous l'avez vu
tout à l'heure dans dans un des
reportages de Gérard griisbeck que toute
la ville de Rome s'est préparé pour
faire face à ce qui pourrait être un des
plus grands le plus grand probablement
mouvement de foule jamais vécu ici merci
Isabelle stè vous le disiez la presse du
Vatican mais aussi la presse fr
française consacre des numéros spéciaux
à la mort de Jean-Paul II c'est le cas
d'un Figaro hors série qui sort demain
c'est le cas aussi du point de la croix
et de Paris Match je vous propose de
refermer ce journal sur ces images de
Jean-Paul i dont la dépouille est
exposée au 2è étage du Palais
apostolique les officiels et la curie
ont pu lui rendre un dernier hommage
aujourd'hui dans un très grand
recueillement et ça n'est que demain
après-midi on le disait que la dépouille
du pape sera exposée au public pendant 3
ou qu jours dans une chapelle ardente
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
remercie de votre attention tout de
suite la météo Nathalie riwe 20h55 le 8e
jour avec Daniel huteuil suivi d'un
documentaire sur Jean-Paul i un pape
pour l'an 2000 demain 13h Benoît du Ken
20h David Pujadas excellente fin soirée
sur
français